Rome is getting tough on tourists on
Friday Rome's mayor presented a new law
banning bad behavior around the city's
popular tourist attractions already
police have been seen cracking down on
people climbing on monuments eating or
drinking in restricted areas and wading
into Rome's famed fountains under the
new law
violators can be banned from the city's
historic center for up to 48 hours Wow
Rome is just one of the places that's
gotten fed up with the crush of visitors
other cities and attractions are
experiencing severe overcrowding and
other stresses brought on by too many
tourists the numbers tell the story
according to the United Nations World
Tourism Organization they're around 70
million international tourist arrivals
back in 1960 today that number has hit
more than 1.4 billion well here to talk
about the effect of all that tourist
traffic is Erin Florio travel news
director for Conde Nast Traveler Erin
good morning good morning so this term
over tourism it's something different
than just a lot of tourists explain what
it is yes absolutely only very clear on
this that over tourism does not mean too
many people are traveling in fact the
travel industry is booming is such an
exciting time to be traveling but what
happens as you mentioned there are more
people than ever traveling now in the
past what happens is all of these people
or a lot of these people are wanting to
go to the same short list of places and
that puts a lot of stress and a lot of
burden on the resources and on the
infrastructure of these places and
that's when over tourism occurs so no
you go yeah you okay say look you know
you should be happy I'm coming to visit
your tourist attraction you know I'm
giving you business sure and I think
that's very fair and look I think most
communities are very grateful for the
dollars that tourism brings in right but
what happens with over tourism is it
puts a massive strain on the local
communities so all of a sudden houses
prices are jacked off people can't
afford to live in the places where their
families have been living there a
supermarket becomes a souvenir store
it's it it affects their day to day and
that's when it becomes an issue yeah
we've seen these places there Venice
popular Paris popular but what is really
driving
this over tourism so I think it's a
number of things like we mentioned
before there are more people than ever
traveling there's 1.4 billion people
that were traveling last year and that
was a number we expected to hit in 2020
and we got there early and it's
increasing so a lot of these people are
going to the same places and there
there's a lack of information about
alternatives the whole world is open for
tourism but they seem to know only only
a few spots and they're going to the
same one you say don't underestimate the
power of Instagram ah yes absolutely
so there's another buzzword in travel
right now outside of over tourism which
is Instagram ability and studies have
shown that about 40% of people that use
Instagram travel based on what they can
post looking for that spot to post and
what's happening is we're seeing these
beautiful places that are very fragile
and they're going in mass and they're
posting about them and it's upsetting
the ecosystem I was in an 11th century
Cathedral in France yesterday watching
dozens of people with their cameras out
the whole time they were like this and
it's such a shame as well because
they're not stopping and actually yes
much more what do you do if you're one
of these cities you want the tourists
but how do you absolutely so actually
Amsterdam has done a great job of
managing their tourism they get 20
million travelers a year and there are a
city of less than 1 million people so
you can understand the burden what the
government there has done as they've
started a program where if you log on to
the websites and you want to say go to
the van Gogh museum one of the most
popular sites NAMM to them they will say
the weight right now is two and a half
hours we suggest you go here instead and
then we direct you to places that that
have a less wait time yeah a lot more
people have access to travel now as well
absolutely a lot of them from China aren
Florio we thank you for being here with
us